fearlessness is jumping off of the cliff
without thinking courage is
acknowledging your fear analyzing the
consequences in deciding you still care
so much about it you're gonna take one
step forward anyway I was buried in
tuition payments I was all out of Bar
Mitzvah cash to make some quick money so
two nights before final exams my
freshman year of college I find tickets
the price is right I believe faith no
matter what your religion is faith in
the idea that it's going to work out in
the end
isn't useful it's necessary need
motivation watch a top 10 with the leave
nation what's that believe nation it
seven my one word is believe and I
believe in you I believe you have
Michael Jordan level talent at something
and I want you to find it embrace it and
use it to make a difference so let's get
your motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
in today's lessons from a man who went
from dropping out of college to then
going on to interview some of the most
successful people in the world and
becoming a best-selling author himself
is Alex vinayan and here's my take on
his top ten rules of success enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one take the third door so after
spending seven years studying the
world's most successful people I
realized while on the surface you know
Maya Angelou and Steve Wozniak might be
completely different at the core their
stories are the exact same and there's
almost this common melody to it and the
analogy that came to me is that they
treat life business and success just
like a nightclub there's always three
ways in there's the first door where 99%
of people wait in line hoping to get in
that's where the line curves are on the
block right and then there's the second
or the VIP entrance or the billionaires
and the celebrities go through and
school has its way of making you feel
like those are the only two ways in
right your other weights your turn where
you're born into it but what I've
learned and what you know is that
there's always always the third door and
it's the entrance where you jump out of
line run down the alley bang on the door
hundred times crack up with a window go
through the kitchen there's always a way
in and it doesn't matter if that's how
Bill Gates will his first piece of
software or how Lady Gaga got her first
record deal they all took a third door
rule number two be courageous one of the
biggest and most surprising lessons I
learned on this journey was that I just
had this assumption that all these
people I looked up to were fearless you
know Elon Musk or Bill Gates we just
assume they you know have no fear and
it's how they achieve what they've done
but what I've learned is that not a
single one of them were fearless they
actually were filled with tremendous
amount of fear so while they weren't
fearless they did have tremendous
amounts of courage and the difference
between fearlessness and courage is that
fearlessness is jumping off of the cliff
without thinking courage is
acknowledging your fear analyzing the
consequences and deciding you still care
so much about it you're gonna take one
step forward anyway
rule number three my personal favorite
be resourceful I had a problem where I
had this dream I thought the easy part
would be getting to Bill Gates the hard
part I figured was getting the money to
fly there I was buried in tuition
payment
sounds all out of bar-mitzvah cash some
quick money so two nights before final
exam is my freshman year of college I
find tickets to the prices right yeah
hey my first thought is you know what if
I go on the show and win some money to
fund this dream yeah you know not my
brightest moment but I had a problem I
never seen a full episode of the show
before I only seen bits and pieces so
that night had decided to do the logical
thing and pull an all-nighter to study
okay but I didn't study for finals I
said how to hack the prices right and I
went on the show the next day and did
this ridiculous strategy and ended up
winning the whole showcase showdown
winning a sailboat so that's how I
funded the book rule number four define
success for yourself how do we define
success can a bus driver on the street
be defined as successful and the guy
who's the CEO of that business not
successful so when I started out on this
journey I had the same definition of
success as almost everyone which is I
thought you know the more powerful you
are the more wealthy you are the more
successful you are you know the Forbes
list idea it wasn't until I met Steve
Wozniak the co-founder of Apple
computers that he completely redefined
my understanding of success he helped me
realize that you know if you put Steve
Jobs and Steve Wozniak side-by-side most
people will say Steve Jobs is more
successful but Wozniak company realize
that success has much more to do with
how you define it how you look within
yourself and ask yourself what do I
actually want what makes me happy and if
what makes you happy is driving a bus
and coming home at 5:00 p.m. and picking
up your kids and playing catch with them
and you're the CEO of a company and
never see your kids you're not
successful if you're miserable if you're
not doing what you want to do that's not
success
so should we broaden ideas of what it
means is a definition flawed I believe
that the natural human and really
Western definition of success which is
more money more power more prestige
isn't right look it might be right
some people who want that but for the
vast majority of people who want to be
you know a mother and working and
helping at their kids school or a father
who wants to be you know involved with
their community I think the idea of the
more Twitter followers you have and the
more money you have is a flawed model
you have to look within yourself and ask
yourself what you want rule number five
survive rejections what makes this book
so interesting man is is your story of
trying to put it together which is at
least as powerful as the stories in the
book if not in some cases more powerful
so how did you deal with rejection oh my
god
horribly you know because pretty much
the whole book at some point feels like
this long string of me getting my ass
beat you know and dealing with that
rejection I realize is not only a part
of the entrepreneurial journey it is the
entrepreneurial journey so how you deal
with it is a lot more interesting than
how you got your win because everybody
will get their win in a different way
but how you deal with the rejection in
many ways as a universal act and what
I've learned is that I do two things one
when I'm getting beat up and doors are
just being slammed in my face over and
over and over again and I have nothing
left the only thing that keeps me
because I've thought about quitting you
know I'm I'm a human being I've thought
about you know is this worth it the only
thing that would keep me going was that
larger belief that we talked about in
the beginning it's not about me there'll
be points on my journey where I would be
you know up by 4:00 a.m. sleeping at
midnight just pounding the pavement and
after you know getting rejected over and
over over again with that kind of
lifestyle you lose your spirit of what
started it and it was my best friends
that would save me and they would be
like dude tomorrow like
taking your phone we're going you know
on an adventure we're going you know
whatever it was and in many ways that
was like my emotional reset which saved
me over and over and over again rule
number six make things happen a friend
of mine who was helping me actually try
to get to Bill Gates said look I'll help
you get to Bill Gates but you should
also talk to cheela and I trusted him
and I went in and I found out that
here's this guy grew up in a village
outside of Shanghai China with no
running water no electricity in his
village was so poor that people walked
around with deformities from
malnutrition but he was a smart guy and
he worked really hard and he got into a
good university and by the age of 27 he
was making the most money he's ever made
in his life $7.00 a month now fast
forward 20 years later and he's the
president of Microsoft he is
single-handedly one of the most
inspiring guys and the way he's impacted
me the most he's taught me a lot of
lessons he's taught me not just about
success he's taught me about
relationships about luck and its role
and about preparation and about
opportunity and about he's taught me the
most crazy sleeping hacks and diets and
he's an incredibly inspiring guy but the
biggest thing he taught me is that he
said the most beautiful thing you would
think someone who grew up in those
circumstances would be very down on his
life and the cards he was out look I am
very aware and I even told him in the
interview I'm aware I grew up in Los
Angeles in the United States with
running water and electricity in public
schools and when she Lou grew up with
his public schools for every 500
students there was one schoolteacher so
I'm sitting with Cheney says the most
incredible thing he goes every time I go
to a movie with my daughter I think oh
my god I'm in a movie theater and it's
such an incredible way to live life and
for someone who's been
who was dealt extremely hard cards he
said the most beautiful thing he goes in
someways life God the universe or
whatever you want to call it is
extremely fair
everybody has 24 hours in a day some
might be born with a silver spoon and
some might be born in a village but
there's an equalizer and we all have 24
hours so it doesn't matter if you're a
peasant or if you're the president you
have 24 hours in a day and it's up to
you how you're gonna spend that rule
number seven have faith I believe faith
no matter what your religion is faith in
the idea that it's going to work out in
the end isn't useful it's necessary
because if you move forward on a journey
without some faith whether it's in the
universe orphans and God it's a very
lonely and scary journey and who knows
what happens up above but it feels a lot
better believing that someone has your
back you can't be a cockeyed optimist or
Kenya uh you know it helped me but it
also got me in a lot of trouble rule
number eight focus on your desires you
talked about turning the volume up on
your dream I want to know what that
really means like what are you saying in
your head it's a brilliant metaphor the
notion that okay you've got all this
noise I'm gonna turn up the volume on my
dreams gonna drown it out but like that
the reality of that is what so this is
the thing I believe fully that every
single person is going out to chase
their dreams has those voices in their
head I think it's part of the human
experience whether it's fear or anxiety
whatever it may be that's part of what
it means to be a human being
so you know for me it was my parents
coming to this country sacrificing for
you it might be completely different
what I've learned in hindsight is that
not just with my story with all these
people who I studied the key of taking
that first step the really daunting
because the first one's always the
hardest as you know it's not about
trying to logically argue with those
voices in our head you will never win
against the voices in your head if you
try to argue with them what I've learned
is that if you instead of focusing on
the voices in the fears you focus on the
desires and I think no matter what your
dream is if you're able to find a larger
purpose a larger impact that lives
beyond you all of a sudden all of your
[ __ ] that's holding you down becomes
a lot less relevant rule number nine
grab on to what you want one of the best
pieces of advice I got on this journey
was the difference between a linear life
and an exponential life a linear life is
you get an internship you get a job you
get a promotion you save up for a
vacation and you just go step by step
slowly and predictably your whole way
through and again there's nothing wrong
with that but you have to be clear with
yourself about what you want an
exponential life is about deciding that
you're not gonna wait around you're not
gonna hope someone just you know hands
you what you're hoping for and it's
about grabbing on to it for what you
want so if you look at Steven Spielberg
the way he did it was he was rejected
from film school so instead of giving up
on his dream he decided he would take
his education into his own hands so the
way the story goes according to
Spielberg is that one day when he's
around 19 years old he jumped on to a
tour bus at Universal Studios rides
around the lot on this tour jumps off
the bus hides in the bathroom waits for
the bus to drive away and starts walking
around the lot and as he's walking
around he bumps into this man named
Chuck Silver's who works at Universal
Television and Chuck Silver's sees this
kid and says what are you doing here and
Spielberg tells him his dream and they
end up talking for awhile and Silver's
goes gonna come back on the lot
Spielberg goes that would be a dream and
Chuck Silver's writes a three-day pass
and Spielberg goes every day back to the
lot for the next three days but on the
fourth day Spielberg puts on a suit gets
his dad's briefcase walks up to the
security entrance puts a hand in the air
and goes hey Scotty
and Scotty just waves back and Spielberg
walks right through and for the next you
know months
Spielberg goes back onto the lot going
into editing rooms learning as much as
possible sneaking onto sets and soaking
it all in we
creating his own education he's asking
producers out to lunch talking to actors
and actresses but eventually Chuck
Silver's who became his mentor gave him
one of the best pieces of advice he
essentially said stop schmoozing and go
make a quality short film that you can
have in your hand and show to people and
it's sort of bust that myth of it's not
you know what you know it's who you know
it's really also what you know or what
you have to show so Spielberg takes the
advice to heart makes this incredible
short film called Amblin and when Chuck
silver sees it he's so moved that a
single teardrop falls on his face and
Chuck Silver's reaches for the phone and
calls the vice president of Universal
Television Sid Sheinberg and he goes Sid
I have something you have to see and Sid
goes look I have a lot to watch right
now is it that important and Chuck's
over goes it's that goddamn important if
you don't watch this tonight someone
else will Sheinberg watches the film the
next day says he wants to see spielberg
immediately and gives him a seven-year
contract on the spot and that's how he
became the youngest director in
Hollywood history and rule number 10 the
last one before some very special bonus
clips is burn your ships so there's this
very famous story from Napoleon Hills
thinking Grow Rich where a general a
long long time ago takes his troops on a
few boats and sails to an island for a
battle and as the troops get off to get
off the boat and the general goes out to
survey his enemy the general sees that
enemy is out numbering his troops ten to
one so he comes up with a strategy the
general lines up his troops
lights a match and sets the ships on
fire and by burning the ships he gives
us troops an option either you win or
you die and sure enough they want it and
when it comes to burning your ships in
your life this is the most personal part
this is when you're almost at the end of
your journey this is the part that makes
the difference between chasing the dream
and achieving your dream and only you
deep down know what your version of
burning airships are so I want to
challenge you when you're at that final
point of your journey
make it your final bullet go all ships
in and when you get to that point burn
your ships
now I've got two really special bonus
clips from Alex on how to be patient and
find your true path that I think you're
really gonna enjoy but before that I
want to make sure we're taking action
not just watch another video so it's
time for the three questions write them
down for yourself talk about them with a
friend or leave your answers in the
comments below here we go question
number one what is your definition of
success question number two how can you
take the third door to reach your
success and question number three what
will you do to keep the faith when you
feel low thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love see
you soon and enjoy the bonus clips
who's the hardest to get bill gates took
two years in my entire focus was on him
it went to the point where I was 18 and
19 years old and I had pictures of him
taped up above my bed on my car
dashboard it was my number one dream and
it took an entire two years of work to
make it happen so all this book took how
many years it was a seven year journey
so it was about four years of doing all
the interviews and then another three
years of writing it as a narrative to
make it a page turning what was it that
was driving you in all of this you know
when I first started to understand like
why I was going through this crisis at
the beginning that led me on this
journey was you have to know that I'm
the son of Jewish immigrants which
pretty much means I came out of the womb
my mom cradled me in her arms and then
she stamped MD on my ass and just sent
me on my way
you know I'm like in third grade I wore
scrubs to school for Halloween you know
I was that kid and by the time I got to
college I remember really quickly you
know I was the pre-med of pre-meds
but I remember lying on my dorm room bed
staring up at the ceiling and looking at
this stack of biology books feeling like
they were sucking the life out of man
and at first I just wondered maybe I'm
being lazy but then I began to question
maybe I'm not on my path maybe I'm on a
path somebody placed him out and I'm
just rolling down so not only am I going
through this what I do with my life
crisis that's when the question started
to evolve to you know how did Bill Gates
when nobody knew his name saw softer out
of his dorm room or how did Lady Gaga
without a single hint under her belt get
her first record deal these are the
things they don't only teach you in
school so I just did what I thought was
normal I just went to the library or
went on Amazon and just ripped through
books you know business books self-help
books biographies but eventually I was
left empty-handed and that's when my
very you know naive HNO thinking kicked
in and I thought well if no one's gonna
write the book I'm dreaming of reading
why not write it myself raise your
standard Apple at the
it's core value is that we believe that
people have passion can change the way
people not one drop of myself work
depends on Europe that's something to me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten roses success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link the description for details